reading your book I thought one of the
things that stood out to me is that we
talked about rehab all the time right we
get injured and we go to rehab yeah you
talk about pliability in terms of prehab
yeah
meaning pliability can prevent injury
yeah I think so
I I absolutely do and that's and these
are based on my experiences and then the
things that I've learned and that's why
I wrote about him and that's you know
part of the education and I felt that I
wanted to do know at this point my life
but as I get older - and you're right
when you're if I think about it from a
football player standpoint you can't
help the team if you're not on the field
plane so why wait to just get hurt what
can you do to prevent injury how can you
you know treat your body to try to avoid
injuries from having certainly ones that
you know happen without any contact
you know guys that you know may hurt
their groin or hurt their hamstrings or
their calves or you know what can you do
to start preventing those types of
things before they even happen and you
know those types of things really
intrigued me you know cuz and I think
that's kind of the way things are going
now you hear a lot more about you know
sports science and people wanting to you
know play longer and what the things
they need to do in order to recover and
I feel like those are the things I've
really been focusing on for 12 years now
so it's not a 2017 thing for Tom Brady
this is something that I've been doing
for 12 years and it's really paid off
and again when you make the investment
in the time and energy and the
commitment to doing it and it's really
paid off like that's a great feeling and
that's why I still want to keep playing
because you know I'm having so much fun
at this point my career
do you have other players and FL players
on different teams call and ask you for
advice yeah I do whenever I'm in contact
with them you know it's different times
you know some people have my cell phone
and a lot of times it's after a game
guys may came up to me or find me in the
tunnel and talk to me or I've had you
know conversations the last few off
seasons with other players and they want
to know you know it's hard to explain in
five minutes what I've written you know
in 300 pages and why would you want to
help Aaron Rodgers he plays for thing
they've happened I know because you know
what I'm by I love athletes and I love
athletes that really want to work
card I've been around them and I've been
around in a locker room for a long time
and you're right you think of those guys
as your competition and and sometimes in
some ways they are in the offseason it
doesn't feel like there's your
competition much but yeah I mean I want
to be able to help you know all athletes
I every time I'm reading a magazine or
something on the internet talking about
another player and he's injured and he's
got this going on it's like I staring
think man if they only had the
information that I had they could
prevent you know these you know these
things from happening